yes we finally got confirmation after so
many years with lightning the iphone is
finally getting usb type c now i know
this sounds absolutely crazy to a lot of
you out there but usb type c is the most
important thing for the iphone and
before i explain why first i've got to
go through these bombshell leaks from
one of the most reliable sources and
analysts out there ming chick
as you can see he just released a new
statement saying that the iphone 15
lineup is going to switch from lightning
to usbc next year and as you can see in
this recent tweet from this morning
framing chico he says that the new
iphones in the second half of 2023 will
abandon lightning and switch to usb type
c and the reason for it is to improve
iphone's transfer and charging speed in
terms of the hardware designs and the
reason why this tweet by mixture code is
so important is because ming chu ko was
actually the one person who previously
said that the iphone would not get usb
type c back in march march 2nd he said
that the iphone would be sticking with
the lightning port over usbc for the
foreseeable future yes he said that usbc
is detrimental to the mfi business's
profitability and its waterproof spec is
lower than lightning and max saved but
the crazier thing that he said was that
if the iphone abandons lightning in the
future it may directly adopt the
portless design with max safe support
instead of a type c usb port and now
just two months later he is completely
flipping the script and saying that next
year's iphones are getting usb c now if
you remember i did a video back in
january about the iphone 14 pro getting
a usbc port as you can see i got these
renders created by renders by shalash
showing off that usb type-c port and i
even made a video telling you guys to
brace yourself because usb-c is coming
but unfortunately i think i was wrong
about usb type-c coming on the iphone 14
pro and it's actually coming next year
but within this video there was a very
very interesting point that i made
listen to this our new connector
is called lightning so now we have
thunderbolt and lightning in our
connector strategy
this connector is a modern connector for
the next decade phil schiller said that
this lightning connector is a modern
connector for the next decade yes that's
for the next 10 years and this event
actually happened in 2012
so the whole basis of my video was what
if in 2022 we finally switched to usbc
well it looks like this is going to be
the last year with lightning and next
year we are getting usb type c and
that's exactly what mac rumors talked
about in this article saying that the
lightning port is near its expiration
date so what's next for the iphone well
of course usb type c now on top of that
the crazier thing is that mark german
who was the most reliable apple analyst
and leaker has been talking about a usbc
iphone for a while way back in 2019 he
said that apple is testing some versions
of the iphone including a usb c
connector that was back in 2019 so it's
been a while and he said that moving to
usbc would make the new models
compatible with chargers used for
hundreds of other devices like android
phones which would be a major benefit
and last year in august he talked about
apple's confusing charger lineup saying
that we have lightning for some of the
ipads and the iphones we have usb-c for
the macbooks and some of the higher-end
ipads we of course have mac safe for
three different
devices and now he's saying that
lightning has served apple well since
2012 but usbc has clearly won out across
the industry has become the default
connector for new devices and yes i
believe that both the pro models and the
regular 15s are gonna be getting usb
type c and that has to do with a brand
new redesign because apple is on a cycle
where every three years they totally
redesign the chassis and i believe
if they're going to be going through all
the trouble of making this redesign as
you can see having like a flat glass
back with protruding glass on the back
and the front like this which is totally
unique then apple might as well redesign
the port i thought that the iphone 14
lineup would be getting this redesign as
you can see we talked about these
different leaks that ross young
confirmed with the dual hole punch
camera as you can see right here and of
course renders by shylesh helped me with
those rumors and man this iphone design
looks sick you got the glass on both the
front and the back circular power
buttons and this actually originated
from john prosser's exclusive leak of
the iphone 14 which happened way back in
september he said that the iphone 14 is
getting a full redesign with these crazy
new design updated speaker grilles
completely flat glass back which
obviously this looks absolutely
beautiful but the interesting thing is
within those renders he kept the
lightning port around and even a couple
months back he said twitter bookmarked
this tweet if the iphone ever gets usbc
i will shave off my eyebrows and then of
course we got a major shift in the leaks
with a lot of leaks of the iphone 14
lineup coming out showing off a similar
design to the iphone 13 that we already
have as you can see the same design as
we have with the iphone 13 lineup but
with larger camera bumps so after that
happened john prosser came out with a
new video saying this is the real iphone
14 finally admitting that it's more
likely that the iphone 14 lineup is
gonna stick to the same ish design as we
already have with the iphone 13 and
within that video he admitted that he
thinks he received his renders and leaks
one year early so he admitted that it's
more likely for that full redesign with
the flush glass back protruding glass on
the front and back to be coming next
year with the iphone 15 lineup so what
all of this means is that this is likely
the design of the iphone 15 pro and as
you can see usbc is probably coming next
year this is super
super exciting so with that said a lot
of you guys are probably saying hey
let's skip the iphone 14 why would we
buy it because the iphone 15 is getting
usbc that's a major major improvement
well let me get into the different
features we should expect and why it
might actually be worth it for a lot of
people to upgrade this year first of all
we have the new lineup with the iphone
14
regular max model now in terms of the
displays we actually got a display panel
leak as you can see right here and dang
the bezels are reduced on these pro
models we have the dual punch with the
pill and the cutout and we have an even
thinner and wider speaker grille which
is going to be barely visible but i
think the really big feature about this
year's iphone at least the 14 pro model
is going to be the cameras this is
literally going to be a camera
revolution with us finally getting a 48
megapixel main sensor capable of
shooting 8k
60fps video but this creates a problem
because shrimp apple pro has confirmed
that this year's 14 lineup is sticking
to the lightning port which is an issue
because if we actually have 8k pro res
video with the new 14 pro with the 48
megapixel camera that is going to be a
ton of storage space being used and how
are you supposed to transfer all of that
using lightning well in my personal
opinion i think that the 14 pro models
this year are gonna feature an upgraded
usb 3.0 lightning connector to
significantly improve the transfer
speeds and to be completely honest i
think this year's iphones are going to
look absolutely beautiful as you can see
in these renders that shylash created
for us they look absolutely amazing
especially with this display redesign
with the thinner bezels i mean this is
going to look awesome and then of course
the last thing i want to add to this
video is next year when the iphone
switches over to usbc we're going to get
a huge wave in the future of new apple
products and accessories getting the
usbc port as you can see this is an
airpods mod ditching lightning for usbc
i think this is gonna be a huge deal to
finally start getting air pods earpods
max different accessories fully
switching to usb type c that's gonna be
awesome so there you guys go those were
all of my thoughts on minxo's leak of
next year's iphones getting usbc let me
know if you agree with me down in the
comment section below and if you enjoyed
this video click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and definitely check out one of those
two right over there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]